the most wonderful time of the year can
also lead to a lot of stress a new
survey finds unrealistic holiday
expectations are weighing on parents and
children it turns out you may get more
by doing
less stephanie mortimer knows the
holiday season can be hectic she's
squeezing in some shopping with her son
eli and their friends we have to
decorate the house we have to get all
the gifts we have to like you know make
sure the kids have a memorable holiday
these days it can feel like the to-do
list is longer than santa's list do you
ever feel a pressure to get it a certain
way for sure yeah
and then you're not sure if everybody
always notices
a new c.s mott children's hospital
national poll finds parents are worried
their holiday stress might take away
from their holiday joy a lot of them
feel like that has a negative impact on
their child's enjoyment of the holidays
and that's just so unfortunate the poll
shows nearly a third of parents are
stressed during the holidays by extra
shopping balancing finances and
especially keeping their family healthy
mothers are twice as likely as dads to
experience high stress and one in five
parents believe their stress negatively
affects their children during the
holiday season sarah clark is the pole's
co-director i think in some families
we're trying to make up for some things
missed over the last year or year and a
half and i don't really think that's the
approach that is going to be most
helpful
experts say to make the season brighter
sit down as a family and ask what
everyone really wants from christmas
keep your favorite traditions alive but
think about what activities you can cut
or minimize
the presence in the holiday spirit and
the meals i guess
what about the elf on the shelf oh yeah
check your to do list twice but try to
trim some of the stress for more joy in
the season
70 percent of parents in that survey say
the best way to reduce holiday stress
get some alone time if you can more than
half said actually listening to music
can help